[Music]  Kourtney Kardashian's new man a unis  been jima here's what you need to know  he's a 23 year old boxer turned model  really cute a stores close to Kourtney  tells Iggy the pair is definitely  hooking up but that it's not serious yet  we love it they met through mutual  friends in Los Angeles we did some  digging one of Eunice's close pals  seems to be 18 year old Sofia Richie  she's all over his Instagram before  Kourtney unis was linked to model Jordan  Dunn so what has got Disick think of all  this  it's hard for him our source says he  still loves Kourtney and his hope  they'll get back together but she's not  interested  there was someone Mart breaking I just  didn't see things going this direction  Scott and Kourtney's rocky relationship  is playing out on their reality show  he's in deep water with a family in  Costa Rica there's a level of respect  and appropriateness if you need to get  your wet that badly and can get your  sweat  [Music]  you